ahora que estamos cómodos con la
geometría de las celdas vamos con
algunos detalles veamos con más atención
el paquete de acabados observa que cada
celda está rodeada de piel y las celdas
sobresale encima necesitamos decidir qué
tanta distancia hay entre el borde de la
celda y el inicio de una escama esta
separación expondrá la piel de donde
salen las escamas en nuestro programa
podemos hacerlo con el parámetro tamaño
de escama si maximizamos el tamaño de
escama cubre toda la piel y eso se ve
mal
así es que necesitamos regresarlo un
poco para obtener la separación que
queremos esto se ve bien pero observa
que la separación entre las celdas es la
misma en todas partes cierto eso no es
muy natural por eso agregamos un control
para variar la distancia entre los
bordes de las escamas eso se ve perfecto
después necesitamos hacer que las celdas
resalten sobresaliendo de la piel
podemos controlar qué tanto resaltan con
el parámetro de extrusión ahora tenemos
un modelo para la piel de dinosaurio al
que podemos empezar a dar acabado
echémosle un vistazo al paquete de
acabados y examinemos los nuestros de
color dice
de escama deberá tener un color
ligeramente distinto y la piel debe ser
más obscura y como el cuero así es que
agregamos en los controles de color por
aquí uno para la piel y otro para las
escamas
para lograrlo usaremos un truco muy
bueno definimos un rango de colores
desde la escama más pequeña aquí hasta
el escama más grande aquí y ahora
nuestro programa le pondrá un color a
cada escama basándose en su tamaño las
escamas más pequeñas van a tener este
color las escamas más grandes este otro
y el resto de las escamas tendrán un
color intermedio eso es genial nos
ahorra tiempo porque si no tenemos que
definir el color de cada escama de
manera individual y ahora de cómo el
color varía de forma muy natural
dependiendo del tamaño de la escama
también agregamos un botón para darnos
una idea de cómo se verá nuestro patrón
muy bien ahora es tu turno de usar todas
estas ideas para crear tu propia piel de
dinosaurio y en el ejercicio final
podremos usar todas las herramientas que
presentamos en esta lección y cuando
estés contento con tu creación
continúa la siguiente elección donde le
agregaremos los detalles a nivel
microscópico eso va a ser genial siempre
tienes primero un modelo y después haces
el acabado la mayoría de las veces
tenemos primero el modelo pero luego nos
damos cuenta que necesitamos una
geometría diferente y queremos agregar
detalles en ciertas áreas del modelo
entonces algunas veces terminamos
cambiando el modelo cuando el acabado ya
había iniciado